Now that we've seen all the code
to render the watch face,
we still need to look at how
the colors were configured.
Let's load up
DigitalWatchFaceWearableConfigureActiv-
ity.
This activity runs on the wearable and
is available
by the little gear icon when the watch
face face is selected on the wearable.
This is a standard
Android Wear Activity.
There's nothing special about it.
It implements a wearable list view, and
shows a list of colors to
set as the background.
If we look at the on click handler, we
can see it calls UpdateConfigDataItem.
This method then sends out updates to
other listeners on
the Android Wear network.
Let's go back to the main project.
If we look at the phone
application project,
we can see
DigitalWatchFaceCompanionConfigActivity.
This is an activity that
runs on the phone side.
It's also a standard Android activity
that brings up some selectives for
different colors in the UI
like we tried earlier on.
This code sends out updates to Android
Wear devices using the message API here.
It can also receive data item
changes made from the wearable
configuration activity as well.
The main difference here is that
the phone side implements many more
configuration options while
the wearable side was kept simple
due to the size of the display